caregivers are ordinary family members
who are stepping forward to look after
their loved ones who have to deal with
various health conditions and needs my
name is Lakshmi
I'm a designer at fuel for we look at
interactions that ordinary people have
with care systems and redesign them it
was 2016 the National Council of Social
Service Singapore came calling
Singapore's caregiving landscape needed
a new approach due to the complexities
of the experience changing demographics
changing families aging population as
well as the maze of assistance to
navigate across media caregiving
experience very lonely and stressful we
conducted design ethnography following
the day two days of 10 different
caregivers experiencing the world from
their perspective
we then synthesize their unique journeys
to create a common framework looking at
the experience of caregiving as a series
of emotional highs and lows seeing
caregiving through this lens opened up
opportunities we knew we could design
specific solutions that will directly
support caregivers at various points and
across the system as a whole
a few topologies emerged we found out
that each caregiver was different and
had different issues and needs it was
important to create different caregiver
technologies because we knew who they
were and what they needed exactly and it
put them at the very center of the
design process we discovered caregivers
are the red thread that connects the
social and healthcare landscape and it
is they that journey with their loved
ones across social and healthcare
services and that's when it clipped the
impact on health and social care as we
know it would be infinitely better if
caregivers were properly supported a
design workshop was held designers
created initial ideas based on insight
then other disciplines came in and
iterated these ideas and added their own
ideas everyone working together until we
got this we designed a physical space
where caregivers can receive support
meet fellow caregivers and attend
coaching programs and a virtual space
that would make it easy for caregivers
to connect and link up with parties and
organizations and sectors online plus a
new role the family manager and the we
care toolkit a practical guide for
social workers
this was a design project but it wasn't
done just by designers we had
researchers social workers health care
workers filmmakers and leaders from
across sectors we even recruited the
caregivers the roles started to blur we
work well together because we had one
unifying purpose research was important
but the end goal is the actioning of the
insights and making it a reality our
ideas were integrated into their
enabling master plan for Singapore this
project has shown the potential of
design and how it can impact society we
want to say that we have found the
answer to caregiving but this is just
the beginning the beginning to
normalizing caregiving as well as
building a compassionate community
through design
you
[Music]
[Music]